well hundreds of thousands of nurses
have spoken up loud and clear today what
they've said to governments right across
the UK and off is enough and what
they've done today is turned their
Action Now into anger and it's
governments that have pushed those
nurses to take the action they've taken
today and vote for strike action and
it's government that can stop it a but
if they don't and if they continue to
turn their back on nursing staff then
unfortunately what we will see is a
strike action across the NHS and across
the UK
what do you want do you want more money
yes absolutely when you think about it
our independent analysis shows that
every nurse is working one day a week
free every week what a way to treat the
nursing staff that hold the Health
Service together so what we want to see
is decent wages paid to nurses so that
we can retain our nurses that we've got
in the system and that we we can recruit
brilliant nurses in to the system
because patients right across the UK
deserve better and nurses deserve better
they're living at the at the minute at a
knife edge in their personal life and
they're getting a pretty Raw Deal in
their workplaces and what I mean by that
is they cannot afford to pay their bills
and look after their families and get to
work and then when they get to work each
nurse that's on duty today and coming on
duty tonight is not just filling their
own post but all of the tens of
thousands of vacant posts that have been
created by this government that's not
much to ask to make sure that they've
got the resources to be able to look
after their patients